mich bewegt das im moment natürlich
logischerweise mit der klimakonferenz
die findet gerade statt dann seit 30 40
jahren von der wissenschaft immer wieder
erklärt bekommen was in sachen
extremwetter passiert wir haben es
gemerkt mit der unglaublichen flut im
sommer wir haben es gesehen in kanada
mit 50 grad wir haben es gesehen mit den
unglaublichen waldbränden mit den neuen
pulverisierten oder die alten rekorde
wurden pulverisiert die niederschlags
rekorden von gema 850 liter innerhalb
von 24 stunden also es verändert sich
was die wissenschaft hat es gesagt und
jetzt kommt eine klimakonferenz
1,5 grad ist es ziel wir sind im moment
auf dem 2,7 grad wir machen seit 1992
relativ wenig wir reden viel wir machen
will nicht jetzt stellt sich das fand
ich spannend boris johnson hin und sagt
das ist aber ein ganz wichtiges thema
ist mir stark aufgefallen weil bisher
ist ja genau durch dieses thema nicht
aufgefallen interessant für mich zwei
punkte man hat ja gesagt jetzt wollen
wir was in sachen wald um 2030 soll die
abholzung aufhören meine frage warum
2030 warum mich früher das sind noch mal
neun jahre bis dahin und der zweite
punkt jetzt hat man sich sehr aufs
methan eingeschossen und das sind ihn
interessant gedanken jetzt hat man
nämlich in ganz großer geschwindigkeit
ein großes thema wo man sofort einen
erfolg verbuchen kann alle sind sich
einig mit haben ist 16 prozent der
klimawirksamkeit man hat das
kohlendioxid noch ein bisschen hin
geschoben also vielleicht gute nachricht
und nachher mal gucken was rauskommt das
thema ist natürlich nicht nur geht es in
aller munde ist auch objektiv sehr
wichtig das ist richtig was mir sehr
unangenehm auffällt ist immer wieder das
wort ihre rede nicht der fall aber das
doch bei vielen die das thema
voranbringen wollten ihrem sinne und
hoffe ich auch unser aller sinne ein
alarmismus vorherrscht er einfach nur
noch abstumpft mich zum beispiel
abstumpft ich reagiere nicht mehr wenn
ich ständig höre die letzte chance für
unseren planeten hat prinz charles
gesagt eine minute vor mitternacht boris
johnson
un-generalsekretär weg haben unser
eigenes grab und wenn ich aufhöre dann
brennt unser haus steht lichterloh dann
kann man nichts mehr machen wenn das
haus schon brennt also dieser alarmismus
ist schadet meines erachtens dieser
alarmismus mit teilweise fast religiösem
fuhr vorgetragen schadet einer wichtigen
sache man muss zur kenntnis nehmen dass
durch verschiedene einschätzungen gibt
was man machen kann und nicht jeder der
ein späteres ziel macht will dass die
noch schneller untergeht ich finde wir
sollten etwas abrüsten es geht ja nicht
darum die apokalypse aufzuhalten es geht
darum vernünftig umzugehen mit den
tatsächlichen objektiven gegebenheiten
teilweise anpassen teilweise verhindern
aber den klimawandel an sich werden wir
nicht stoppen können wir müssen menschen
mitnehmen und das geht einfach nicht
wenn ich sie beschimpfen oder
quasireligiöse verstockten gehöre es
darf keine klima religion werden es ist
eine klimabewegung auf ich bei bei
klimaregionen der religionen da stellt
sich bei mir immer so ein bisschen die
nackenhaare auf also ich glaube da sind
wir gar nicht aber es ist natürlich
unheimlich schwer es fällt also wie geht
man es anders wir haben in den in den
80er jahren schon gemerkt haben wir auf
einer zeitschrift die mit anfängt und
mit igel aufhört da hat man den kölner
dom draufgemacht ins wasser gestellt und
gesagt so dramatisch da wurde das wort
klimakatastrophe erfunden ein erfolg ist
dadurch nicht zustande gekommen und so
für mich vollkommen bei ihnen wenn wir
apokalypse erzählen ohne ende dann sagen
die leute nachher ja und jetzt sagen ja
eh nichts machen also im übrigen ich
glaube übrigens ohne die eigene direkte
erfahrung und menschen wird wenig
passieren das ist und das ist ziemlich
schwierig denn die dritte ja erst später
ein wenn alles so kommt wie wie
prognostiziert wird und ich glaube das
ist wirklich schwierig ist motivation
auszulösen solange man in seinem garten
sitzt im schrebergarten oder in seinem
kleingarten die vögel zwitschern die
sonne geht auf man kriegt vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr sonnenbrand als früher
aber machte also es ist nicht eine
unmittelbare bedrohung erkennbar anders
als bei pandemie oder hochwasser das ist
auch wirklich mein kernpunkt also diese
dieser schleichende prozess irgendwann
passiert irgendjemandem irgendwo
irgendwas das ist ganz schwierig das
können wir nicht bei corona da konnten
wir das da hatten wir eine konkrete
bedrohung haben wir ganz viele dinge
getan beim klimawandel nicht jetzt ist
aber doch die frage wie gehen wir damit
um also weil unabhängig von dem was ich
richtig fand was sie gesagt haben wir
erreichen alle ziele nicht so also
dieser weg den wir einschlagen nutzt
nichts immer wieder darüber zu reden
kein erfolg zeitigen was müssen wir
machen ich glaube wir müssen die dinge
wirklich zerlegbar machen wir müssen das
war über ist wirklich einer der gründe
für dieses besser machen buch wo ich
einfach gesagt habe hey guckt euch doch
die sachen an die erfolgreich
funktionieren last eine kombination
wirken aus wir werden am ende nicht den
erfolg haben mit alle können alles zu
einem beliebig geringen preis machen das
wird nicht gehen wir werden mit
einschränkungen zu tun haben aber
einschränkungen im sinne von wo kann
eine einschränkung auch eine an eine
positive energie freisetzen und letzter
satz von mir nur weil ich auch durchaus
die technik für einen ganz wichtigen
punkt halte ich bin ein freund vom
technischen möglichkeiten um unseren
horizont das haben wir schon ein paar
mal gemacht auf dieser welt etwas zu
erweitern und sich herausstellt da muss
doch das aber auch mal sagen wir regt
jetzt hier immer noch in so einer in so
einer weltuntergangsstimmung es ist doch
eigentlich so dass wir gerade in
deutschland deutliche steigerung unserer
volkswirtschaftlichen produktivität
hatten und gleichzeitig ist der co2
ausstoß gesunken das sind fast
gegenläufige kurven das ist ein sehr
großer erfolg wird oft so als müssten
wir uns ganz dramatisch einschränken ich
glaube nicht dass einschränkungen
tatsächlich der richtige weg ist sondern
der technologische weg ist eigentlich
das worauf es ankommen wird sie sind
fdp-wählern ja dazu sage ich die kleinen
aber es ist ja gut aber
ich glaube dass es eben wichtig ist
wirklich beide dinge parallel zu machen
und ich glaube was sie eben gesagt haben
diese empfindung diese wahrnehmung dass
wir bei den menschen angekommen wann der
klimawandel wurde hat sich durch die
dürre durch die unwetterkatastrophe
plötzlich kam er bei den menschen an
plötzlich gründete sich durch den berg
friday is for future das heißt diese
gemengelage die die wirkt die arbeitet
und jetzt müssen wir ideen auf den tisch
ich glaube was jetzt vielleicht zum
heutigen zeitpunkt auch noch mal
relevant das ist den klimagipfel
tatsächlich auch als chance zu begreifen
weil
klimapolitik kann ich nur auf
länderebene verbleiben selbst sind von
einschränkungen sprechen oder von
veränderungen des verhaltens etc wir
müssen verstehen dass es ein globales
problem ist das als solches begriffen
werden muss und ich hoffe dass sozusagen
die vertreter die sich jetzt bei dem
klimagipfel zusammen gefunden haben die
sich auch vorgenommen haben tatsächlich
die fünf jahre sozusagen zu überprüfen
was denn erreicht wurde die ziele die
man sich auf nationaler ebene gesetzt
hat jetzt noch einmal auf den prüfstand
zu stellen und ich glaube dass das die
möglichkeit ist tatsächlich in die
zukunft zu blicken und konkrete
maßnahmen festzulegen damit man alsbald
als
globale gesellschaft tatsächlich im
klimawandel voran kommt es gibt einen
riesenfehler aus meiner sicht und
systematischen fehler in den
klimakonferenzen und er ist ganz einfach
es gibt einstimmigkeit für das
abschlusskommuniqué 190 länder wir haben
das ja schon mit europa gerade gehabt
190 länder sollen sich also einig seien
unterschiedlicher wirtschaftlicher stand
unterschiedliche geografische lage
unterschiedliche kulturen das ist das
profil mit den müssen weg von dieser 1
wenn es jetzt mehrheitsentscheid gibt
dann entscheiden die reichen über die
armen
deswegen bleibt also was sie sagen
natürlich richtig ist ja auch logisch
man die sorge die ich habe wenn ich also
einige wie ich finde sich sehr ungute
radikalisierenden stimmen aus der
klimaschutz bewegung höhere sondern höre
ich immer wieder auch system change and
climate change also müssen das system
ändern die transformation auch der
demokratie also one man one vote soll
dann revidiert werden die bekämpfung der
pandemie von corona also als blaupause
genehm genommen werden für die
bekämpfung des klimawandels
einschließlich einschränkungen von
grundrechten einschränkungen von
eigentumsrechten und das finde ich sehr
sehr schwierig und das darf nicht sein
wenn ich also den eindruck habe und die
stimmt gibt es leider den kampf gegen
den klimawandel als instrument zu nehmen
demokratische grundrechte zu schleifen
weil das die riesige aufgabe ist die
alle anderen rechte schleift dann sage
ich nein da schütten wir das kind mit
dem bade aus die demokratie müssen wir
bitteschön retten und dann halt nur ein
satz dazu die andere seite wenn man
jetzt natürlich also das ist jetzt der
klimaschützer jetzt kann man die
klimaforschung sollte man natürlich
nehmen und ihre gruppierung die sich
positionieren und natürlich auch nicht
gerade im übermaß demokratie freundlich
agieren wenn aus häusern das immer genau
das erleben wir müssen es als
gesellschaft schaffen die sie diese
extremen lage reden legen indem wir wir
müssen einfach die chancen im
mittelpunkt stellte können wir anfangen
das glaube ich es wichtig und ich also
ich habe ein totales vertrauen auf die
nächste generation
also
ja weil sozusagen ich glaube dass wir
viel zu sehr in ein dirigistische so ich
will jetzt nicht sagen das wird sich
ergeben wenn wir nichts tun aber wenn
ich sehe was was meine töchter umtreibt
wie die
handlungen im täglichen leben blicken
die für mich normal sind die aber für
sie ich würde sagen abstoßend aber
sie in eine andere zeit gehören glaube
ich dass wenn die sich mit ihren
freunden mit ihren generation mit ihrer
generation sozusagen anders zu verhalten
beginnen dann verändert sich auf ganz
wunderbare weise was sowie die nächsten
generationen immer etwas ganz
wunderbares sozusagen verändert hat ich
hätte mehr zutrauen in eine normale
entwicklung und nicht so sehr in wir
müssen wir müssen jetzt erwachsenen
umerziehung durch regeln und verstöße
und keine ahnung aber wir brauchen
natürlich rahmenbedingungen aller welt
und gab den rahmenbedingungen wie sie
heute sind das ist so wer die umwelt
verschmutzt kann reicher werden als wäre
sie sauber hält wenn ich sowas habe dann
geht das ding am ende nicht auf und da
muss ich mich politisch und aber
deswegen ja nochmal der klimagipfel dort
die länder die am meisten emissionen
ausstoßen das sind ja diejenigen die man
auch in die pflicht nehmen muss und da
bringt es auch nichts wenn deutschland
als nationalstaat versucht an der stelle
so große fortschritte zu machen ohne die
anderen staaten zu mit einzubeziehen
aber ein umgekehrter satz deutschland
liegt auf platz sechs aller emissionen
187 länder emittieren weniger als wir
das heißt wir haben schon eine große
position auch wenn zwei prozent wenig
ist es ist viel weil ja der gesamt
kuchen durch 200 länder geteilt ist
immer klein also am ende ist unsere
aufgabe eine große und wenn man
natürlich hingeht und am ende sagt weil
die anderen nicht mitkommen machen wir
jetzt auch erstmal langsam
das haben sie nicht gesagt aber darin
beschrieb die gefahr und ich glaube die
müssen wir weg räumen sondern ich sehe
aber schon in deutschland irgendwie so
an gewissen klima größen waren da hat
man ja den eindruck als könnten wir
jetzt die welt retten wir müssen
sicherlich die weichen richtig stellen
wir müssen da ja auch als als g7-staaten
in der verantwortung irgendwie
voranzugehen er aber dazu schon ersatz
von meinem großvater wir hatten globus
im wohnzimmer stehen und dann sagte er
passt mal auf mich zeigt immer was guck
mal hier ist deutschland kombi wir sind
hier so wie mein kleiner fehler so klein
sind wir ja und wir wollen jetzt die
welt retten also das ist irgendwie eine
selbstüberschätzung mitunter die ich
nicht nachvollziehen kann man muss ja
sehen wie viele kohlekraftwerke in china
im bau sind diese ja gar nicht immer
alles richtig war jetzt so als geht
verzicht einfach europa hat bestimmt
recht aber wenn der opa natürlich
emissions- karten machen würde und die
länder in der größe der emission
abbilden würde dann wieder einmal
ziemlich dickes deutschland und immer
wieder sagen die linie ihren anderen
auch aber völlig richtig wir stellen ja
auch teilweise durchaus nach bestimmten
umweltstandards her wenn bestimmte
produkte bei uns nicht hergestellt
werden würden dann würden sie woanders
wahrscheinlich klimaschädlicher
hergestellt wenn das muss man auch mal
diese rechnung mit einbeziehen werden ja
schon viele in china hergestellt und wir
brauchen sie nachher